did you ever wonder what would happen if
guiyu arrived a day earlier or if kagaya
sent someone else to the infinity train
instead of rengoku or even better what
would happen if Tundra was born with the
Demon Slayer Mark well I spent months
researching these topics and here is
exactly what would happen if Geo managed
to arrive a day earlier it would mean
that he would be around the mountain
when muzan attacks the Commodore family
since he is a hashira we can assume that
he'd be able to sense muzan's presence
and would rush toward him as fast as he
could after getting there guiyu wouldn't
believe his eyes as the Demon King's
been chasing for so long is finally
within his grasp he'd quickly tell the
commodos to escape while he stalled The
Demon King for time so how would this
battle play out well although gu is
surely one of the strongest Ashira he
stands absolutely no chance against
muzon in a battle he may be able to
stall for a minute or two but in the end
he would be crushed okay get you died
but at least tanjaro's family escaped
and will be alive in this version of the
story right right well not really since
muzon defeated pretty quickly he'd catch
up with the commodos in the blink of an
eye and eliminate them all as he wanted
from the start as the sun rises Tundra
makes his way up the mountain and same
as in the original story he finds his
family dead and nezuko turned he would
immediately rush to find a doctor but
since Geo is not alive to meet him at
this point what will happen to him you
see the information about muzan's
appearance would probably reach kagaya
who would then send all available
pillars to his location this would mean
that Tantra who was running down the
mountain and the hashiras who are coming
up would probably cross paths so how
would this interaction go well one
important thing to consider here is that
since guiyu has died the hashiras are
really angry and as soon as they sense
nezuko they won't hesitate to kill her
Tundra would try to persuade them
telling them that nezuko is different
but they would kill her without
hesitation it's crazy to think that this
little change would lead to both nezuko
and Kiyu dying in episode one but what
would happen to tondero well after his
sister's death he would go mad and try
to attack the hashiras of course he
wouldn't be able to do anything to harm
them but it would make some of the
shiras see his potential it's probably
shinobu that would sympathize with
Tantra the most as she also lost her
sister to Demons she would accept tandro
as her sugoku and train him to be a
Demon Slayer tanjaro would become pretty
strong easily passing the final
selection and defeating many weaker
demons however as soon as he engages rui
at Mount natugumo his luck would come to
an end tantro stands absolutely no
chance of defeating rui without nezuko's
help and rui would easily deal with him
using his blood demon art murderous eye
basket okay this scenario doesn't really
have a happy ending but you'll
definitely like this next one what if
someone else was sent instead of rengoku
on the infinity train Mission well if
someone weaker than rangoku was sent for
example shinobu or tenjen everything
would play out pretty much the same they
would most likely save all the
passengers but in the end they'd be
killed by akasa same as ringoku so what
if kagaya sent someone stronger like
yomei for example how would the mission
turn out then four starters since Young
is blind all of his other sentence are
much more developed in my opinion yomi
would be able to sense that there is
something wrong with train tickets and
would not touch them touch them he would
also tell the trio not to touch the
tickets this means that the group would
avoid enmu's trap and stay awake the
whole night as you can guess and move
would be furious with this development
and would attack the Slayers and
passengers in full force however since
he is only a lower Moon yomei would
easily keep all the passengers safe
while the trio goes and decapitates enmu
okay so far everything has played out
pretty much the same but what will
happen after akaza arrives can the
strongest hashira do anything against
him Yumi engages akaza in combat and
they appear to be evenly matched at the
beginning unlike rengoku the stone
hashira has some really strong
long-range attacks which would help him
keep his distance beyond the reach of
the Demon's fists if akasa tries to
attack him with his Shockwave attacks
yomi can easily deflect those using his
Stone skin technique now since yomey
doesn't yet have the transparent World
ability it would be very dumb to assume
that he could just keep a Kazakh away
like this forever akaza is an upper moon
at the end of the day and would surely
manage to get close to the hashira at
some point and injure him with his
attacks akaza being akaza will probably
asked jomek to become a demon as he does
with pretty much all his enemies and the
latter would obviously decline breaking
a cause's heart please subscribe to make
a Kaza happy again I think he would be
very grateful eventually with both of
them heavily injured the sun will rise
and a tasa will be forced to flee and
you know what this means yeah that's
right no history died during this Arc
this means they will all be alive for
the final fight against muzon later in
the story just imagine if another
hashira was there during the final
battle it would be game changing also
it's possible that some slayer's muzan
has defeated like mitsuri and obanai
would survive in the end man I really
wish kagaya sent someone stronger on
this Mission the story's ending would be
much happier all right but did you ever
think about what would happen if Doma
was in the Entertainment District
instead of gyotoro and daki if you are
wondering why would he even be there you
probably missed one important piece of
information in season three you see
during utero's flashback we learned that
Doma loves eating girls because because
they are very nutritious because of this
he often comes to the Entertainment
District because it's filled with
beautiful girls so it actually makes a
lot of sense for him to be there so how
would this scenario play out the
start normally with zenutsu enosuke and
Tundra disguising his girls and
infiltrating three houses everything
would continue as usual until zenitsu
hears a weird sound coming from one of
the rooms however when he goes to
inspect instead of finding daki as in
the original version he finds Joma
feasting on multiple girls zenitsu would
prepare to attack him but with threes
with fear as the demon turns his head
and reveals the kanji inscription of
upper two in his eyes the young Demon
Slayer would panic and run for his life
he would shout for tension and others to
help him while Doma would playfully
chase him down with a creepy smile on
his face as initsued approaches the dead
end dumbass swings his fans at him but
out of nowhere enosuke tantro and
tengens jump in and block the attack at
the last moment as the young Slayers
check on their friend tenjin notices
that Doma is an upper Moon and he yells
to the boys to run away from here as
fast as they can although zenitsu is
eager to run away Tundra and anosuke
stand up letting tenjin know they are
not going anywhere tension would call
them naive and stupid telling them that
this demon is way out of their league
however the boys have already made up
their minds and are ready to fight Doma
Smiles as the demon Slayers engage him
at first dumu would play with them
effortlessly dodging their attacks and
complimenting their techniques knowing
doma's personality he would probably be
angry at the core for sending only male
Slayers to fight against him he would
ask them to please bring a female
hashira next time they fight him this
attitude would enrage the trio and they
would recklessly jump toward him however
Doma is nowhere close to the demons they
fought before and would swiftly impale
all three of them using his wintry
icicles technique completely
incapacitating them as he smiles he
fails to notice that tension is already
right behind him the hashira swings his
blades at the Demon's neck and just as
it seems he'll manage to land a hit his
hands are suddenly caught by doma's
lotus vines before the trio can even
react Doma stabs tension through his
chest fatally injuring the sound pillar
Tundra would stand up Furious ready to
attack Doma however with his last breath
tenjin yells at him to run away telling
him that if he dies now rengoku's
sacrifice would be for nothing Tundra
would get flashbacks of rengoku telling
him to live on and would immediately
snap out of his anger he'd carry
unconscious inosuke and zenitsu on his
shoulders and run as fast as he can
while tears run down his face since the
dawn is very close Doma wouldn't bother
chasing him and would probably yell from
a distance to please bring a female
pillar next time they meet man Doma is
so overpowered I am really glad he
wasn't around the district at that time
okay finally what would happen if
tanjaro was born with the Demon Slayer
Mark like yorichi well although many
amazing things will happen in this
version there are actually some very bad
things this would cause all right let's
start from the beginning with the power
of the Demon Slayer Mark we can also
assume that Tantra will have a
transparent World ability same as
yorishi since his family never taught
him about demons and fighting he'll most
likely be completely clueless about his
powers and would live his life as usual
selling charcoal in the village this
means that his family will eventually
get killed and that he'll encounter giyu
due to his transparent World ability
Tundra would cause much more trouble for
dyu and the latter eventually has to use
water breathing to stop the bullet
seeing tantro's incredible potential GUI
would personally take him as his tsugoku
and train him to become a Demon Slayer
okay here is where things start to get
really good as chontro is now much
stronger he'd be able to help her and
Goku and defeat akaza using a
transparent World which means that
rengoku would survive he'd also easily
defeat butero which means tenjin will
continue being a hashira by the time of
swordsmith Village Tantra would already
completely have mastered Sun breathing
and would easily kill hontengu on his
own before mitsuri even arrives Demon
Slayer core would be stronger than ever
and with Tundra fighting alongside them
what could possibly go wrong well the
fact that the core is incredibly
powerful is actually a problem in itself
you're probably a bit confused by this
so let me explain you see muzon doesn't
engage in battles he is not sure he can
win remember what happened after he lost
to yorishi that's right he went into
hiding for dozens of years until he was
absolutely sure yorichi was dead so try
to put yourself in moves on shoes Demon
Slayer core is the strongest it was in a
long time some of your upper moons were
defeated for the first time in 100 years
and on top of all that some kid appeared
that can use the Demon Slayer Mark
transparent world and Sun breathing yeah
right muzon is definitely not engaging
Slayers directly anytime soon the only
reason Slayers won in the original story
is because he heavily underestimated
them and thought he could just kill them
all easily a mistake he definitely won't
make now so all hashiras will remain
alive in this scenario they will kill
countless demons and save countless
lives but will never find the one demon
they want the most eventually Tantra
would die of old age and the demon king
would rise from the Shadows once again
and this time there will be no one left
to stop him click on this video where we
explained what would happen if muzon
turns yorichi into a demon don't be shy
click